hey everybody it's Michael alos founder
and Trader at orderflows decom and today
I got a special video for you it's uh 15
questions and answers on orderflow
trading now these are questions that
people have written to me in the past
you know either posting them online or
you know on my YouTube channel or
whatever you know I I I try to get back
to everybody you know sometimes I'm a
bit slow sometimes I unfortunately I do
miss emails I get a boatload of emails
and you know about 90% of them are spam
but you know I I try to get to theil
when I can and yeah these are are
general questions about trading not just
on orderflow and and the orderflow
software but on on trading you know with
the orderflow in general so um you know
I I hope that you guys will watch this
video and you know have some of your
questions answered now I realize you
know some of these questions people
probably never even thought of um you
know in your trading and how it can
affect your trading so hopefully you
know you can learn one or two little
tidbits in in this video so before I get
started brief disclaimer this
presentation is very educational
informational purposes only is not
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a Futures Contract or make any of type
of investment this the decision Futures
Trading contain substantial risk and is
not for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading P
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results and again
you know another disclaimer I think
people should be aware of
is you know one of the reasons why
results vary a lot is because you know
it really depends on the individual you
know if you as an individual as a Trader
you know are taking the steps to follow
you know what is being taught whether
it's by me or whether it's by somebody
else um you know that's going to have an
impact on your trading results so you
know you could go take a seminar with
somebody you know pay $3,000 $5,000 for
a week
and you know sit next to the person and
the person just literally transfers
every bit of knowledge that he has to
you it's up to you to put it into action
okay that's what's your success or
failure is going to fall on it's going
to fall on you you know I know I know
people like to blame others for their
lack of success in life actually um but
it it doesn't come down to it it comes
down to what you as an individual can do
you know I've worked in the professional
world for 20 years right and I mean
that's not a lot you know I know people
have worked there for 50 years 60 years
but still you know the point is you can
see how you know when you new people
come into the office you know who's
going to be successful who's not going
to be successful you know who's just
going to be your average employee you
know it's the ones that take it upon
themselves to want to learn more
understand more know how things work
rather than just sort of come in punch
the clock do your eight hours go home
like that you know it's there's a
difference right it's what you as an
individual do and and that spills over
into trading into you know your
relationship your everyday life so
anyway I get off the soap box there
first question these are not in any
particular order of importance these are
just you know I just been writing down
questions you know out of my notebook
and I flipping through it and then I I
took 15 today so number one is what kind
of charts do you use do you use minute
based charts range based charts Rinko
based
Etc I used to use minute based charts
now I use range based charts and the
reason why I use range based charts is
because you know I like to see how price
moves in relation to the market you know
I don't want a bar to close because oh
it's 9:30 and I'm using a 5- minute
chart and it's 9:30 so I got to close
this bar open a new one like that I want
to see how price rotates around the
auction and you know whether you know if
the price is moving up or price is
moving down you know I want a new bar to
form as price is moving up rather than
hey oh it's it's
1037 okay I'm using a 1 a chart it's
time for a new bar no I I don't I I I
don't think it's as useful in trading as
say a range based charts now ranco based
charts you know there's so many
different types of Rinko based charts
now um you know I've tried ranko based
charts honestly and you to me it didn't
really make that big a difference in my
trading versus Range based charts now
again you know there's these other types
of you know uni Rinko this Rinko that
Rinko and you know people do send me
charts you know and often I'd say about
a third of the charts that traders of my
software send me are Rinko based charts
you know asking me to comment on their
analysis and you know so I I know there
are a lot of people out there using them
and you know some people are are quite
successful using them although you know
honestly I've never met a professional
Trader JP Morgan or Cargill or any of
these other companies looking at a Rinko
based chart um you know but that said
most of those Traders are more long-term
based chart uh Traders you know not
necessarily day trading you know they're
more of Swing Traders at a minimum and
more of a long-term
Traders
and you know the other base chart is I'd
probably say like a tick chart I I I do
use tick charts I do look at like um 987
tick charts 987 is a um is a fib number
uh in some markets I use as little as a
100 tick chart now I do use uh minute
based charts on on a few occasions I I
do keep 15-minute charts open
and I keep a one minute chart open in e-
minis you e- minis just trades a bolt
load of volume in a very short period of
time so you know I mean I I like to look
at it but uh I don't really use it that
much majority of my trading 95% of my
trading is is range based
charts number two what's the best time
frame for trading orderflow well that
sort of goes back to the first question
you know what kind of charts I
use I use range based charts and you
know on a range based chart it can take
30 minutes for a bar to form and so it's
it's hard to say in that sense now
intraday trading is suited for orderflow
I mean it it's not something you're
going to look at you know three days ago
information with orderflow you really
you want the most recent information so
you know intraday trading is you know
for order fly I mean I get people that
for some reason you know they're they're
swing Traders and for some reason they
want to try order flow but they're
holding their positions for like three
days and you know I tell them well
orderflow is not suited for that so you
know I mean based on how I trade and how
I teach
orderflow so you know intraday time
frames are best for order flow I'm not
going to say you know on a f minute
chart or a one minute chart um yeah I
know people that use it on minute based
charts one minute charts I know people
that trade with three minute charts I
know people that trade with 5 minute
charts really about as far out as You'
go I think it's about a 10-minute
chart question number three what range
what why do I use a 10 range and a four
range e mini chart now okay so you know
an important part of trading is is
having a chart that you're comfortable
with trading okay I use mostly four
range charts for nearly every contract
out there that's a slow moving contract
uh I slow moving I mean you know things
that you know trade a lot of volume and
you know it's going to need a head of
steam to make a move so for example um
bonds 5 years 10
years
buns Euro stocks uh e mini S&P I use
four range charts you know soybeans I
use four range charts corn I use four
range charts I use a 10 range chart for
E minis as well and the reason being is
there's days when the market is
slow and there's days when the Market's
got a lot of volatility like uh Monday
and you know last week I think it was
last Friday right you had like a 40
Point range 30 point range you know 10
range chart is going to be a lot more
useful on a day than very volatile than
a four range chart you know four range
chart in the e- minis is something I
would use when the market is calm and
you know there's no numbers coming out
and it's just sort of rotating around
value but at 10 range you know on on a
market that has a lot of volatility I I
like to use wider range charts now I use
eight range charts for Euro currencies
Japanese Yen crude oil NASDAQ NASDAQ I I
think I got a bust out to a 10 range
chart I don't like to go beyond 10 range
I find you 10 range is about as wide a
range as I'm comfortable with using on a
chart even hang saying I'll use a 10
range chart Dax I use eight range
actually now what trade what platform
does orderflows Trader run on I it runs
on ninja Trader 7 ninja Trader 8 and we
have a Sierra charts version Sierra
charts is with with a another partner of
mine and you know if you're interested
in it just uh let me know I'll give you
the information on that but you know as
far as ninja Trader which version do I
think is better I think ninja Trader 7
is better ninja Trader 8 you know ninja
Trader is really making that push to get
people out you know it's taken them
three years to get Ninja Trader 8 out
and you know last year they just
released it you know like right around
Thanksgiving when earlier in the year is
when they were really planning on
releasing it and you know at some point
they're going to stop I say at some
point you know realistically they're
going to stop supporting ninja Trader 7
and you know when is that I don't know
you know sometimes these guys with Ninja
Trader you know you send them even when
they're doing all that testing for Ninja
Trader 8 you know like myself my program
other people I know would send in our
our issues with Ninja Trader 8 and they
would just say oh well you know it's
still in beta you know it's like well
you're asking us to send in our issues
and you know the way you you you put it
off is like ah you don't really care
about it it's like well why you asking
for our feedback but you know it runs on
ninja Trader 7 I know people that I I
use personally I use a ninja Trader 7
I'm probably going to make the switch to
ninja Trader 8 pretty soon it's just a
matter of one or two issues that I have
um I use it in the trading room ninja
Trader
7 but ninja Trader 8 handles data much
uh much more efficiently than ninja
Trader 7 so you know ninja Trader 8 is
obviously the future with Ninja
Trader ratios uh you hear me talking
about in my videos ratios now ratios are
orderflow analysis put into a numerical
form again it's not some big
mathematical equation basically it it
takes um the order flow in a
bar and you know just puts it into a
number and spits it out and you know
there's certain numbers that I find you
know when it's above a certain level or
below a certain level that I find
interesting you know most most of the
time 90% of the time you're just going
to get your average order you're not
going to get any special number any
special ratio but really you know ratio
when you're deal with the order flow you
deal a lot with with ratios even in
imbalances right a buy and imbalance is
when you know volume traded on the offer
versus what's traded on the bid is above
a certain ratio um you know 4:1 usually
is the industry standard and you know
that that's you know another form of
ratios in order flow but you know order
flow you're comparing what's happening
in volume right cuz order flow revolves
a lot around
volume what is point of control PC uh
poc in a bar in this case in in
orderflow is the point of control in a
bar the level with most volume traded
okay and usually it's highlighted with a
uh black rectangle around it it's it's
pretty clear once you look at an
orderflow footprint chart I don't have
charts in this presentation explain trap
Traders number seven you know trap
Traders is a term I don't really like
the term but you hear it a lot
I I I use it actually sometimes in my in
my videos but you know trap Traders are
is people that are basically long and
wrong or the opposite you know the
caught short and the Market's rallying
and you know these guys are you know
usually they they're day traders that
you know even to a lesser extent
scalpers that you know they they're
buying at a level at a high think of the
Market's going higher so the market
turns around and all of a sudden they're
sellers because they got they don't want
to be riding a big losing position they
just get out they're trapped they
realize it and they get out and it shows
up in the order
flow but let me just explain why I don't
like the term trap Traders is because
you know it's very misleading and you
know I mean there's enough liquidity in
pretty much every single Market even in
these less liquid markets and and trust
me I trade um some very liquid markets
like palm oil that you know you can get
out you can get out you know it's unless
the market goes Limit Up limit down you
can get out just you know how much pain
you want to take before you get out so
you know when you think of trap Traders
you're thinking of people oh they can't
get out you know they're they're stuck
you know where they're going to get out
no I mean it's just a matter of pulling
the trigger and you know I think it's
sort
of you know when you think of trap
Traders you know we like to think of
retail Traders the people that lose a
lot
and yeah I put myself in I'm a retail
Trader I mean I don't I don't want I
hate to use the term you know I'm well
I'm a professional retail Trader oh
you know everybody that's
unless you're trading for a bank or uh
or you know a fund or you know commodity
house you're a retail Trader you know
there's big retail Traders but you know
the reality is you know I'm a retail
Trader I don't try to put myself out as
being I'm a professional Trader even
though you know trading is what I do to
pay the bills and all that it's you know
I'm still a retail Trader in that sense
now
you so when you think of trap Traders
really you think of you know these guys
retail traders that often show up late
to the party you know Market's rallying
they come in they start buying and
buying at the high the market is going
higher starts selling off and you know
they get out you know way much lower
whereas you know when you think of
scalpers you know scalpers they're
trying to buy the breakout at a high
realize they're wrong really quick and
get out very fast they're you know
that's that's the difference between a
scalper and and Retail Trader is you
know a scalper willing to cut his loss
without even thinking about it you know
he realizes he's wrong and you know he
just cuts it um you know that that's the
difference between a a good uh scalper
and Retail Trader uh most people you
know most retail Traders don't have that
um don't have that in them you know it's
sort of a trait that takes a lot of time
to to get you know and and not
everybody's just going to come to
trading and you know have that ability
to cut a loss really quick like that
number eight what's the difference
between a volume footprint chart and a
dome well a dome depth of Market volume
footprint chart is what actually traded
and you know volume footprint chart
shows the volume trading on the bid
shows the volume trading they offer a
dome
shows what's on the bid what's below the
bid what's on the offer what's above the
offer and shows people you know layering
in their bids and offers pulling them
playing their games and you for me the
big difference
is Comm commment versus intent a dome
shows someone's intent a volume
footprint chart shows someone's
commitment you know when you're on when
you have a position on you're committed
to the market at some
point you know you're going to want to
get out I mean now people say no not
everybody gets out yeah okay I do
understand you know people take things
to delivery I took I've taken things to
delivery when I was at Cargill and you
know that portion of the market is so
small it's so small that it's not even a
question and you know nowadays you know
you got lot of people hedging stuff you
know versus you know Delta one desks
things like that now yeah but you know
the majority of trading is you know
someone gets in a position they're going
to get out whether it's today tomorrow a
week from now two weeks from now 90% of
the volume that's traded is eventually
someone's going to get out of it now a
dome again it's just people showing
their intention you know if the market
is six bid at 7even all of a sudden a
lot of you know a big bid comes in at
Five Below the market or at four you
know people get scared you know honestly
you know these these Dome Traders and
think oh you know I should buy I should
you know we're trading six bit at seven
someone's put in a bid to buy a th at
five well the Market's six bid right
honestly if the Market's six bid and you
can buy at five then you know you're in
the money right but you're not going to
trade fives until the sixes go so you
know and I understand all the games
people play with domes I used to play
these games with domes
and you know I I just find for trading
purposes it's better to make decisions
based on what actually Trad
versus you know what someone's intention
is right you know
it's how how to put it in in everyday
terms
um you know okay think of it like dating
right you know there's a lot of pretty
girls you know you go to a bar a lot of
pretty girls out there and you're
sitting there with your buddy saying I'm
going to ask that girl out yeah then you
know going to live happily ever after
I'll have three kids well unless you
actually get up off your butt and ask
the girl
out you know you're not committed to the
relationship sh if you're just there
talking about it you know you're just
there scouting the room out saying oh
yeah that girl looks nice that girl
looks nice you know that's like looking
at the Dome whereas once you ask the
person out you know set up the date to
have dinner and so on then you know
you're committed to that position so to
speak you know on a dome you're not you
know you're just sitting there scouting
oh maybe I should do this maybe I should
do that you know and it's that that's
the
difference what are the best markets to
trade okay well again I'm a Futures guy
right and you know my background CR is
on
Futures so pretty much every Futures any
Futures Market you can trade you know i'
I've looked at
literally just about every every
conceivable Futures Market in the world
I've traded South African white maze
I've traded tokom rubber um you know
Zuki red beans you know a lot of these
very very small markets and you know
believe it or not orderflow actually
works on them to the extent that you
know not everything is going to work
because you know some analysis you need
a little bit more volume but you know uh
supply and demand is what drives the
market right and how can you tell what
supply and demand is it's well it's
based on what's
traded does it work with Forex not
really I mean the problem I have with
Forex you know I got into arguments with
people and some people are just
downright nasty um you know because you
know maybe they're they they think
they're a Forex God or something you
know they're out there trading their um
you know their little micro account you
know where one pip is 10 cents or
something I think Forex is the greatest
thing but the data on Forex is crap you
know you've got every different Forex
dealer out there basically with their
own feed so and then where you get your
data feed to run through your charts
often times is through someone else so
you know it's it just it's you I don't
know they just don't understand how the
Forex Market works you know you know
some people it's like my wife honestly
you know I got speak softly so hear it
is
you she just learned how to drive a few
years
ago and you know I've been driving since
I was 16 years old you know so I've been
driving for about 30 years she's been
driving for two years yet she's there
telling me how to drive oh don't get in
this Lane stay over there you know go
over there you know don't don't get
behind this card you know I'm just like
would you be quiet and you know and and
sometimes you get these guys that you
know these Forex guys again you know and
I'm sure I want to get a lot of nasty
comments about this I mean but Forex is
a good Market I've traded Forex
but you know the ideal Market to trade
order flow is on Futures Market you know
markets that have um centralized data
you know even stocks I mean can you
trade stocks yeah there's certain things
in stocks that I look for in
orderflow but ideally the best form is
going to be in Futures that have
centralized data you know dark you all
these dark pools in the equities markets
you know Forex if you're
trading through a white label excuse me
through a white label through some
broker you don't know where the data is
coming from you know and you know the
data you could be looking on your screen
is going to be different than the bid
offer in there and you know the other
thing is you know everyone says well
Forex is great because you don't have uh
commissions well yeah but you're
goinging at the edge you know you can't
work a bid you can't work an offer you
got to basically buy the offer or sell
the bid so that's a big
difference again you know I'm not a
Forex guy and I've traded Forex don't
get me wrong but you know I just find
for trading purposes Futures is a
terrific vehicle they've been around for
hundreds of years is orderflow easy to
use number 10 is Overflow easy to use
well once you understand it yeah it's
it's great you know once you start
looking at overflow chart you'll never
want to look at
another bar chart I mean you will but um
you know I mean for trading decisions
you'll feel like you're not getting the
complete picture of what's going on and
you know is orderflow easy to use yes it
is because
once you understand what's going on in
the market you know your trading
decisions basically become second
nature and you're going to be making
these decisions you know automatically
you're going to be anticipating you
going to see the market unfolding before
your eyes and you'll be able to
anticipate what's going on in the market
you know where it should go okay if this
bar is going to end up like this I think
the market should go this way and you
know you're going to be not trying to
predict the future but you're going to
be basing your analysis on what's just
happened because you know these things
repeat themselves not exactly you know
Picture Perfect repeat but you know they
you see what's happening over and over
and over and you know you can anticipate
basically what's going to happen next if
is you know if ABC D
happened EFG generally is going to
happen it's not going to be ABC D
happened then qz u x happen you know it
it tends to follow in order
number
11 and you know just sort of going back
on that you know is it easy to use you
know once you understand it you
internalize it right it's like learning
to drive right you you learn how to
drive at an early a I say early age you
know in your teens you learn how to
drive and you know as you get more
experienc driving you know even you
internalize the whole Driving Experience
and you know so you know what's going to
happen what you you I say not know
what's going to happen rather you know
when you know you're driving down the
street all a sudden dog jumps out you
know how to react you don't have to sit
there and flip through oh my God what do
I got to do a dog's jumping out you know
or you know a car swerves in front of
you you know what to do you know if
you're driving in the rain you know what
to do if you driving and hit a patch of
ice you start skinning generally you
know what to do and you know that's part
of internalizing the market and when
once you internalize order flow it
really becomes super easy and again it
doesn't take you it's not going to take
you 10,000 hours of screen time it
should you know take you a while to
learn depends again it's I can't say
it's going to take sobody two weeks and
going to take someone two years it
really depends on how much time you have
to devote to it and you know how open
you are to the ideas and and Concepts
you know some people have a very closed
mind and they come into it and you know
they don't want to expand their mind so
to speak but if you do then you know
it's going to be very very easy to use
very
quickly so again you know number 11 is
orderflow just the latest fat in the
training World well it's not actually
order flow has been around much longer
than you know technical indicators
maybe the only thing that hasn't been
around is you that hasn't been around as
that's been around longer than orderflow
is prob candlesticks candlesticks Trace
their date their history back you know
to the what is that the 1700s back to
Japan when people were trading rice but
you know order flow goes back at least
100 years goes back to you know the tape
readers tape reading is orderflow and
you know if you've ever read
reminiscence of stock operator the guy
was a tape reader basically he's an
order fil Trader and you know so you see
these people on these message boards
like you know don't trade or trade in
their Sim account saying oh you know
order flow is just the latest fat it's
not you know maybe the way it's
formatted now it looks like a fad or the
latest thing in the trading world but
you know the whole thing of reading the
order flow in the market has been around
for 100 years and it's going to stay
there right it's it's not going anywhere
you know and what's happening is now
with the Advent of computers it's taking
the data you know more data is available
that wasn't available before for one
thing too with computers are putting it
into a more digestible format that makes
reading the orderflow a lot easier so
again you know you're just taking the
same data that's that's out there you
know it's not like taking some fancy
data it's taking the volume Trad on the
bid the volume traded on the offer
putting it on a nice easy to read chart
know that's not doing anything you know
super fancy it's not taking numbers and
out of its thin air and creating them no
it's taking the numbers the information
the data that's available data that the
exchange puts out you know in the past
right when there was a trading floor you
know traders that traded on the order on
the floor you know they had access to
order flow in the terms of they could
see the orders coming into the market
you know they smart I say smart but
sharp locals would sit there they would
watch you know they'd watch the big desk
Solomon Brothers Goldman Sachs um Smith
Barney Northern Trust you know all these
firms that had big Traders trading you
know in that particular market and they
would see okay oh the clerk picked up
the phone he's going to start looking
you let's check out the bid office her
maybe start flashing in some orders you
know they know that you know the person
on the other end of that phone is a big
Trader generally and you know if all of
a sudden the big you know the clerk is
way W even trying to get the pit
broker's
attention and he watches you know he
sees the guy start signaling hey bye you
know touching his touching his head you
know with his fist closed you know buy
100 then a guy's going to be in the pit
buy as as much as he can as before that
order can hit the pit you know that's
why exchange memberships cost so much
before is because you know people they
would have that edge you know in a sense
they could see the order flow coming in
as as it's coming in and actually they
were able to see it and react to it
before it hits the market you know and
in some of these
markets you know there would be big
Traders right they would know that okay
that um tutor would trade through ex
broker and you know and at certain times
of the day you know a certain hedge fund
would call up to balance their um their
fund at a certain time you know at 3:00
so you know all of a sudden they see
Comer's bank is is starting to buy S&S
at
345 you know there's a good chance
they're going to be buying it for the
next 15 20 minutes and you know so you
know that information was available to
pit Traders where it wasn't available
necessarily to the rest of the world and
you know now with computers you know
it's more Anonymous but if you could
read the bid offer and what's going on
and you know make heads or Tales of it
you know which is what I try to do I try
to people whether or not you believe me
or not it's up to you I don't give a
you know I know
people don't take to orderflow because
you know they can't wrap their head
around it and they don't want to believe
in it but you know whatever you know
there's so many different ways to
approach the markets you know this is
how I've approach the markets this is
what I've done for 20 years you know at
very high levels you know I said you I'm
not trying to brag but you know you
don't last that long at a trading firm
for you know years you know eight years
at JP Morgan unless you know what you're
doing and you know you you can read the
mark market and and
you're basically making money for the
firm so you know is it a fad no it's not
you know it's understanding the market
basically is is what's going
on number 12 I want to make money
trading will overflow help me yes it
will you know but again it's up to you
to take that step
and you know learn it right I said I
could sit here and I could you every day
you know I put out well not every day I
I put out videos you know trade recap
videos and sometimes I talk about the
same thing every single day you know I
say okay here's you got your ratio and a
Divergence and the market sold off from
a high right down to the low next day
ratio with Divergence Market sold off
from the high right down to the
low I don't know what else I got to do
to convince you that you know ratios
with Divergence is a good setup you know
but you know some people I I didn't I
don't want to take it okay well okay
well I can't help you it's not going to
help you unless you know unless you let
me help you and you know so again you
know you could make trading but money
trading but again it comes down to you
as a Trader are you willing to take that
step you know I know I know some people
are scared you know I mean money's
involved hell I'm scared sometimes when
uh you know I've got a position on and
it's and it's going against me I'll be
honest you know I'm not like Val Kilmer
in in Top Gun you know Iceman where I've
got no no fear but um you know the
problem I have with that character is
you know he doesn't like Tom Cruz cuz he
says he's dangerous well if you're icean
you shouldn't be afraid but anyway um
you know it's it's one of those things
where you know yeah I can only help you
to a certain extent but then you know
you still got to go the next few steps
after that right I mean it's you that's
got to click the buy button click the
sell button you know it's up to you to
still take trades you know I could show
you you know the on the map where to go
but you know if you if you're not going
to go in that direction then you know I
can't help you you know again you know
realize life example every day my wife
asked what do you want to eat for dinner
well I want to eat this I don't want to
eat that well then why you asking me
what I want to eat um you know is and
same thing with trading you know can you
make money trading yeah you can if I
think if if you follow orderflow look at
for these setups yeah you can make money
well I want to do that well okay then
why why you coming to me you know why do
you want me to help you if you don't
want to take the steps that I'm I'm
trying to show
you what is market generation at
information again it's a term I use a
lot you know people say why you use that
term Market generated information well
all information that you see on the
chart is comes from the market yeah I
know that but you know when you're
looking at orderflow footprint chart
right you see what's happening in in
real time like literally down to the
tick now again I'm not a dome based
Trader right I'm a footprint-based
Trader you know Dome based Traders is
really like living and dying by every
tick a footprint chart is sort of a step
back and you know you're basically you
know you're looking for certain setups
that is just you know literally as the
market is generating this information
right now right here you're basically
making your trading decision based off
it you know when you use like say
something like macd or moving average
you know you're you're using a lot of
information that is stale already
whereas you're using Market Genera
information right if if you're familiar
with what an imbalance is in the order
flow sounds a bit like Star Wars there
an imbalance in the flow you know
imbalance in in the force but um you
know when you an imbalance as soon as
you see an imbalance coming in that's
Market generated information that you
can use that very few people have access
to or they I'll say have access everyone
has access to it if they're willing to
get a footprint chart up on their screen
but most people don't you know knowing
where the point of control is in a bar
that's you know Market generated
information and how it's you know in
relationship to a high or a low you know
that's you know Market gener information
is information that's generated right
now that you're basing your trading
decision based off of you know if you're
using vwap you know vwap is volume
weighted average price right it takes a
long period of I say a long period but
you know certain period of time to form
a number right that's technically that's
Market generated information but you
know that's not what I'm talking about
or based on the last couple trades you
know that's really Market generated
information to me you know most
upto-date
information that I guess I put has most
up to dat information generated from the
market so if you're such a good Trader
why you selling this why you teaching
people why don't you just go on an
island and trade for yourself I've
thought about that actually and you know
I've done that but you know I said you
know I spent 20 years working in various
firms and you know I do kind of miss
working with they communicating with
other Traders I'm now at the point where
you know I sort of have a nice little
network of people that I communicate
Comm unicate with on a fairly regular
basis but um and you know as a as a
Trader right again I could put this
stuff out for free no one probably
listen to me um you know I sell it you
know people still probably don't listen
to me but um it's it's one of those
things where you know it's again why do
I sell it if I'm such a good Trader and
I just don't live off the trading money
well honestly I'm at that point where
you know do do I really want to keep
doing this yeah I do because I like
working with people I like when people
write to me and say you know what Mike
you know I found you you know searching
on the internet I've watched your videos
I've dissected them so you I have over
150 videos up on YouTube and you know I
put out a trading course you know people
just say you know I've watched your
videos and I've picked up a few things
I've applied it to my trading and I'm
finding myself being a little bit more
consistent you know I'm making I'm
having more days of making money than
losing money you know and they just they
thank me and as a person that makes me
feel good right I I never wanted to be a
teacher in school you know I hated
school but you know now you know I don't
mind you know working with people that
want to learn right and you know
honestly I got to put a price on it you
I can't just give it all for free you
know it takes time you know I got to buy
you know certain things you know
microphone you know a stand you know
things like that you know it's it's not
a big money maker in that sense it just
sort of you know covers the cost B and
you know at the same time you know I get
to meet people work with people that
that want to trade you know again I I
still trade I've still I've got Accounts
at several Brokers and you know so it's
it's not like I'm doing this instead of
trading you know honestly though you
know when I get the hate mail I I do
think of just giving it up say why do I
bother you know these people are are
killing me um you know they they think
that they own me not just cuz they
bought my software but again you I I
don't want to discourage people but
again you know it's up to you as a
Trader to become successful I can only
take you so
far that you know you have to take some
responsibility for your life in general
as well again it said you know I I could
teach you the setups and I do teach
people the setups you know I said here
look for these three things in the
market that's all you got to do you know
I think you could survive on just one of
them but I give you you know often three
or four different things you could look
at just I just say just look for that
don't look for anything else don't try
and get confused on anything you know
don't try to put everything together at
once you know that's where a lot of
people lose sight of what's going on is
they often times try to put everything
together you know I I cover a lot of
ground in my trading course right you
know it's 20 lessons in my trade about
18 you know first one and the last know
first one is sort of introduction order
flow last one is um or the last two is
you know sort of like a recap and just
sort of putting it together but again
you know I cover you know so there about
16 or 17 lessons in there different
things you know and often times everyone
you know people I find that struggle a
bit they try to put every single thing
together at the same time no look for
one or two things concentrate on
imbalances concentrate on ratios
concentrate on point of controls
understand that inside and out then you
can move on to the next point but when
people are putting it all together at
once they're often putting it together
you know incorrectly you know like I've
got kids and you know they make a mess
and you know sometimes I'm just so it's
very late at night you know and it's
messy and you know my my wife's a bit OC
obsessive compulsive and if the house is
not clean she can't sleep so you know
I'll help her my kids got about 50 toy
cars I'll just sort of round them up and
put them in a corner and you know cuz I
just want to get to sleep also but oh no
it can't be that it's got to be all
exact in order well you know what do you
want to do do you want to sleep or do
you want to make sure you know the color
cars are color coordinated before you
can sleep you know me I I just want to
make sure it's all tidy good you know
then I'll go to sleep you know but you
know and there are people like that
where you know they can't take a trade
or you know do a trade unless they think
everything is perfect aligned up well
you know what the market is not going to
be perfect right it's not going to be
exactly the same every single time you
know things are going to be a little bit
different you know I talk about ratios
with divergences if you don't have a a
ratio show in the bar you have
Divergence look to the next bar you know
and sometimes there's another bar in
between the two which you know sort of
you know messes it the whole setup up
but again you know it's Market is
constantly trading you know so one
example is not going to look exactly the
same to the numbers as the previous
example so again you know at the end of
the day it it comes down to the
individual person you know do you want
to be successful or not
you know again that that the decision is
up to
you aggressive buyers and sellers what
are they well okay so you know the first
of all you know when back in the old
days when I was you know at these uh at
these firms you know you call why is the
market moving well there's more buyers
than sellers no there's not what you
have actually is more aggressive buyers
than sellers are more aggressive sellers
than buyers if the Market's selling off
and you know it's zero something game
okay you for every buyer there's a
seller but there are times when there
are aggressive buyers more aggressive
buyers than sellers you know when the
Market's moving up or when the Market's
moving down you have more aggressive
sellers than buyers and again that shows
up in the order flow I mean that's
Central to orderflow analysis basically
and you know by determining what the
difference is you know when aggressive
buyers are showing their hand or sellers
you know you you can you know that's
where your profits are going to come and
you know order flow makes it easy to see
that now there's four types of buyers
and sellers okay you have aggressive
buyers you have aggressive sellers
basically people that buy at the market
or sell at the market they're being
aggressive right the market is six bit
at seven and someone buys sevens they
are an aggressive buyer if someone sells
sixes they're an aggressive
seller
now okay but then well who's on bid at
six who's on the offer at 7 well those
are passive buyers and passive sellers
they're people working limit orders
waiting for the market to come to them
you know whether they could filled or
not I don't want to say they don't care
but you know they're willing to take
that chance that they don't get filled
you know they're a passive buyer you
know if the market six bid at seven you
could buy sixes and sell seven all day
you're going to be a passive buyer or a
passive seller right so if you're on the
bid at six you're a passive buyer
someone sells into your bid fills you
you know that person that sold you this
you sold it to you at six is the
aggressive seller um you the best way to
think of it is when you go to buy a car
okay you know say you I was looking at
um x what was I looking at uh Chevy
Suburbans you know about $40,000 $50,000
a car right depending on your your setup
and you know for
example you think your budget is you
know 42,000 okay you go to the
dealership and in your mind you're
willing to pay $42,000 for that car but
you go to the dealer see the car you
like okay you ask the salesman how much
is a car oh it's
50,000 okay so you know he's happy to
sell it to you at 50,000 you're happy to
buy it at 42,000 well no trade's going
to occur because you guys are too far
away from each other a trade will occur
if the seller the car dealership gets
aggressive and sells it to at your bid
you know so now you know you're willing
to pay 42 he's at
50 and all of a
sudden nothing's happening you just
there staring at each other now the car
dealer is thinking okay you know
this guy's at uh 42 I don't want to sell
it at 42 but you know I'll take a loss
and you know he'll be thinking you know
and next week I've got you know another
50 cars coming in so I'm going to be I'm
going to be long cars but I got a buyer
here but his price is too low so what
can I do so all of a sudden the buyer is
like thinking well I don't want to pay
50 that's too much um maybe you maybe I
can get him interested if I go up a
little bit so the buyer says okay I'll
go up to 45 so now he's bid buyer's bid
at 45 to buy the car dealer
okay uh you know he's interested so boom
seller goes down and hits the bid at 45
and so the seller is the aggressive one
I know people are going to say no well
you know the guy went up on his bid bid
but he's still bid there right he's
still taking that chance of not getting
filled the aggressive seller the car
dealer wants to sell that car he wants
to sell now boom he hits the bid at 45
okay so you know at the same time the
sell the card said no you know I'm stuck
at 50 I can't can't sell for less than
50 then the buyer would have to pay 50
if he really wants the car otherwise
he's not going to get the car then in
that case you know if the buyer paid
50,000 for the car he would be the
aggressive buyer the car dealer would be
the passive seller so that's difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers um and you know passive buyers
and passive sellers you know if you want
to get into the position now generally
you're going to be aggressive and you
know there's times when you know the
people think the Market's going to
really start moving that they're going
to get aggressive and get active you
know you can't you can't participate in
a move unless you get into it and oft
times you got to be aggressive to get
into a move that doesn't mean every
single time you got to be aggressive
people get into markets working bids and
offers I do it but you know you also
take the chance of not getting in but if
you want to get in you're going to be
aggressive right and generally you
you'll transact at the market
price okay so you know that that's 15
questions that I've I get asked quite
often um you know I'll try to do these
videos I like doing this stuff you know
it gives me a chance to talk about other
things than um
you know trade Recaps and you know I
find it quite refreshing actually so
again you know thanks for watching this
video you know subscribe to my YouTube
channel you know I try to put out videos
fairly regularly you know time
permitting and you know I try to you
know share as much as I can with people
and if you want to take your education
further you know visit my website
orderflows decom um you know I've got a
trading course I've got an inner circle
I've got a uh you I've got software so
you know there's a lot of different ways
you could learn orderflow you could
learn for free you know based on the
things that I teach you in these videos
or if you want to speed it up and you
know really accelerate your learning
then you know take the plunge right
become you know become a member of
orderflows doccom so thanks everyone and
hope to hear from you bye-bye